[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing a topic i
personally find rather interesting a
question which you may or may not have
asked yourself while reading or watching
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
how does the sorting ad choose which
house each student goes into at hogwarts
can it see the future so where to start
on this one well anyone who knows
anything about the harry potter series
will of course be familiar with the
sorting hat the enchanted object that
single-handedly selects which house each
first-year student will go into upon
their arrival at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry this selection
process is the focal point of the
sorting ceremony the main event if you
will of the first evening spent at
hogwarts each and every school year it's
a rite of passage eagerly awaited by
some students such as draco malfoy who
was so certain that his future house
would be slytherin just as he desired
and absolutely dreaded by others such as
ron weasley for fear that he wouldn't be
sorted into the same house as the rest
of his family with so much emphasis on
how the sorting selection impacts the
young witches and wizards it could be
quite easy to take for granted how the
sorting hat makes these decisions that
is it's not surprising that we never
hear harry or others question what the
hat's process is for selecting each
pupil's house which serves as their home
for the remainder of their time at
hogwarts after all it would be easy
enough to believe that this process
simply just happens the hat is placed
atop each new student's head and it just
knows where to sort each of them
sometimes the hat announces a pupil's
destined house without barely touching
the hair on the head
other times minutes go by before it
shares where a student should be placed
there's even a name for the instances
where it takes sorting hats longer than
five minutes to decide on a student's
house hat stall but regardless of how
long it takes the sorting ants to come
up with an answer it does indeed provide
one and no one ever thinks twice about
the outcome that is no headmaster
professor nor student ever challenges
its decisions although there is that one
time that albus dumbledore mentions in
passing to severus snape that he thinks
perhaps hogwarts sorts their students
too soon but in any case whatever the
hat says goes and according to jk
rowling the sorting hat is notorious for
refusing to admit it has made a mistake
in its sorting of a student so if it had
decided to place harry and sutherin
instead of gryffindor young mr potter
would have indeed spent his time at
hogwarts in southern house regardless of
how he or others felt about it which
brings us right back around to the very
question of how the sorting hat makes
its decisions if it's so steadfast in
any one choice that it makes regarding a
student's placement it must have a good
reason
it's hard to believe that it's just a
stubborn old enchanted hat so can it in
fact see the future the idea behind this
theory is that if the hat knows what
kind of person or which or wizard will
grow up to be then it can swiftly and
correctly identify their defining
qualities and place them in the most
suitable house
or perhaps once the sorting hat is
placed upon a student's head it's able
to peer into their future and extract
the things that matter most their
prospective career their forthcoming
accomplishments and interests and so
forth but being able to see the future
is a rather tricky thing to base a
decision on
because if the sorting hat can see the
future wouldn't it just be able to see
which house it chooses to place a
student in in a few moments why go
further into the future than it needs to
when it could simply look to the
following year or even the next moment
to see what house that pupil is in
this presents a bit of an issue in
itself is it placing students in a house
because that's where it sees it has
placed them in the future to me this is
a real chicken before the egg scenario
hard to know what came first if you know
what i mean
regardless i believe that the fact that
the sorting hat sometimes takes a rather
long time before announcing a placement
suggests that at least to me that this
theory of the hat being able to see the
future is flawed there's also the
argument that if the sorting hat could
see the future wouldn't it have made an
effort to not place witches and wizards
with inclinations towards the dark arts
in slytherin house a house notorious for
producing graduates who end up dabbling
in dark magic i mean i suppose but i
think it's rather unlikely that the
sorting hat concerns itself with the
outcomes of the future if it can see the
future i don't believe that it has any
stake in whether or not a wizard such as
tom riddle becomes the next dark lord
it's simply an enchanted hat tasked with
sorting young students into a house that
best suits who they are and potentially
who they will become
this would of course be rather different
if it was also given the role of
preventing future wizarding world
conflicts all the like but as we know it
hasn't been in any case i think this is
irrelevant because as i mentioned i
don't think i believe that the sorting
hat can see the future here's why with
hat stools and harry as prime examples
we know that sometimes the hat doesn't
have a clear answer for where a student
belongs and as we've discussed if it
could see the future wouldn't it already
know where each wizard should go
so if it's not able to predict or see
the future how is it making its
decisions in order to answer that
question we must take a look at how the
sorting out came to be well the sorting
hat as legend will tell you the hat once
belonged to godric gryffindor one of the
four founders of hogwarts this would
explain its rather shabby look and
patchwork design it's an incredibly old
hat however once you put aside its
appearance the sorting hat is truly a
one-of-a-kind enchanted object with
spectacular abilities
this is due entirely to the fact that
all four founders of hogwarts bestowed
their intellect upon it and as it turns
out the sorting ant is more than just
intelligent and insightful it's also
incredibly skilled at legitimacy for
those of you who may not know legitimacy
is the practice of using magic to enter
one's mind interpreting their thoughts
and capabilities this branch of magic is
much more than simple mind reading as a
legilimens is able to peer into
another's head bring forth memories and
assess the content of a mind we see this
clearly demonstrated when the sorting
hat is placed upon harry's head when he
first arrives at hogwarts in the
philosopher's stone saying to harry you
could be great you know it's all here in
your head and that slytherin will help
you on the way to greatness no doubt
about that
no well if you're sure better be
gryffindor
in this instance the hat is able to look
around inside of harry's mind using what
it finds to deduce which houses would be
a good fit for him southern or
gryffindor now hold on you may be saying
how could a hat be skilled at legitimacy
and this is a very valid question as
legitimacy is a rather difficult magical
skill to master for most witches and
wizards never mind an enchanted
inanimate object of course there were
certain exceptions to this rule for
example queenie goldstein the american
witch from the fantastic beasts series
was born with her legitimacy abilities
however being born gifted with the skill
to enter another's mind is quite rare
typically one must start with a spell
and an incantation before eventually
being able to perform legitimacy without
words or ones so the question remains
how is it that a hat is able to exercise
this type of magic so effortlessly well
as it turns out witches or wizards who
had the ability to perform legitimacy
were also able to pass that skill onto
inanimate objects this of course is what
happened with the sorting hat the four
founders of hogwarts godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw helga hufflepuff and
salazar slytherin were all legitimates
themselves and each of them bestowed
their legitimacy skills upon the hat for
the very purpose of continuing to fill
their houses with the students who held
the qualities each of them valued most
even after each of them passed on which
brings us to the end of another video as
always i'd love to know what you think
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you